اكرم امام اوغلو عمده اسطنبول حكم عليه
بالسجن عامين وسبعه اشهر واستبعاده من
العمل السياسي طوال مده العقوبه هو احد
رموز المعارضه التركيه ينظر له كمنافس قوي
محتمل للرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه العام المقبل امام
المئات من مناصره امام اوغلو غياب العداله
في تركيا
[موسيقى]
هذه القضيه يقودها اشخاص لا يريدون القيم
مثل العداله والديمقراطيه في تركيا
مرددا عباره يستخدمها وزير الداخليه ضده
قبل بدا ساعات عرض هذا الوصف رئيس بلديه
اسطنبول للملاحق القضائيه بتهمه اعضاء
المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات
في قضيه يرى محاميه انها سياسيه بالدرجه
الاولى
ست الشناور باشا هذا الحبوب في توقيت تسع
فيه المعارضه التركيه الى الاتفاق على
شخصيه قادره على مواجهه اردوغان في
الاستحقاق الرئاسي المقبل هذا وتظهر
الاستطلاعات ان امام اوغلو هو من بين
الشخصيات القليله القادره على الحاق
الهزيمه باردوغان
[تصفيق]